salut salut à tous aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler des premiers vulgarisateur
des premiers hommes de science de
lettres ou d'art qui ont voulu
transmettre du savoir des connaissances
au plus grand nombre
qui était-il à killers ouvrage s'adresse
est il et comment procéder petit c'est
ce qui va nous occuper dans cet épisode
candy vulgarisation la première idée qui
puisse nous venir à l'esprit c'est
peut-être la fameuse encyclopédie de
diderot d'alembert
il est vrai que les premiers essais pour
un large public au 18e avait une visée
symbolique très forte c'est le siècle
des lumières ou et savants se sentent
investis d'une mission civilisatrice en
dalle au peuple il faut instruire pour
remédier aux maux de la société et en
particulier l'obscurantisme chrétiens
donc c'est essentiellement un point de
vue moral
beaucoup voient dans le progrès
scientifique le salut de l'humanité
beaucoup mais certains al'inverse pense
comme rousseau par exemple que la
science pervertir et les vertus story
naturelle de l'homme pensait que la
vulgarisation n'existait pas avant dix
huitième siècle est une idée fausse
avant 18e siècle il a bien évidemment eu
des tentatives de sécurisation plus ou
moins aboutis mais sous un autre format
que celui habituellement destiné à
l'église et au gouvernement
le tout premier scientifique célèbre
avec la risée et galilée qui dans le
dialogue sur les deux principaux
systèmes du monde en 732 opte pour un
italien populaire plutôt que pour le
latin on pourrait également citer dans
la même veine bernard palissy artistes
et savants et ses discours admirable en
15/100 80 qui choisit lui aussi d'avoir
recours à un langage vulgaire c'est à
dire en langue du peuple pour traduire
ses découvertes en refusant la langue du
pape
ces deux auteurs montrent leur volonté
de rendre publiques et accessibles leurs
découvertes scientifiques
je vous présente ses auteurs en même
temps car leurs livres à leur manière de
vulgariser et semblables tous deux ont
recours au système de questions-réponses
qui évoquent leurs titres d'ouvragés
dialogue discours et vous verrez qu'à
l'intérieur il a toujours au minimum
deux personnages qui s'affrontent d'un
côté le scientifiques expérimentent face
aux référents du savoir classique alors
il faut savoir qu'à cette époque le
savoir classique ça fait référence à
l'école scolastique dont les principes
scientifiques dépendent des dogmes
théologique
on commence à vouloir montrer que les
résultats scientifiques ne coïncide pas
avec le discours religieux dans le temps
cette époque il s'agit de faire
comprendre que la terre n'est pas le
centre de l'univers est un peu de
théâtralité
en tout cas une façon orale de
transmettre du savoir ils sont
nécessaires cette mise en scène c'est
une stratégie pédagogique de la part de
qualité et de palissy pas les sites son
côté va développer les cabinets de
curiosités des lieux se rencontrent les
érudits et savants avec comme public
dénommé des courtisans des collections
très diverse d'objets secret petit à
petit l usage des scientifiques
commence alors une époque de
classification de ses biens en parallèle
à ces petits lieux d'échangés de
conversations vont se construire de
véritables institutions du savoir en 16
166 et fondé l'académie des sciences de
paris par louis xiv et colbert
cette construction permet au pouvoir
royal de s'approprier les découvertes
scientifiques
c'est eux qui loge et qui fournissent
comme atos c2 qui contrôle les
publications scientifiques
le rôle de l'académie n'est pas
d'enfermer savoir mais plutôt de mettre
au service de l'état en découvrant des
techniques nouvelles et en collectant
des intentions au profit du roi on
pourrait croire là qu'il s'agit d'un
retour en arrière où le roi est l'unique
bénéficiaire des découvertes
scientifiques
c'est pas tout à fait ça si l'académie
n'a pas vraiment vocation à diffuser le
savoir
son secrétaire bernard de fontenelle a
bien conscience que les sciences sont
utiles au sens où elle forme la
réflexion elles sont un divertissement
un plaisir de l'esprit dans un plaidoyer
en faveur de la science qui paraît en
il souhaite que l'on continue à
vulgariser et il s'emploie à rendre
publics les découvertes au moyen de
journaux tels le journal des savants
c'est aussi un moyen d'accroître le
prestige de son institution comme ses
prédécesseurs sont pas libres au
potentiel du dialogue il va même faire
du dialogue scientifique un genre
littéraire à partir de ce moment les
éditeurs vont multiplier les
publications de ce type
ainsi l'idée d'une science amusante
émergent comme le laisse penser quantité
d'ouvragés qui paraissent à cette époque
où pourrais citer le livre de jacques
ozanam récréation mathématiques et
physique en 16 194,6 fontenelle et
galilée ont choisi comme mode de
diffusion du savoir le livre est bien à
linverse certains savants préfère
d'autres modes de transmission en
particulier l'abbé nollet qui après un
séjour en angleterre où il constata que
les
fayence été rendu public donnera des
cours inspiré du modèle britannique
il insiste sur le caractère visuel pour
transmettre du savoir
fontenelle parler d'amusement ici il ne
suffit plus d'un texte
il faut l'illustré nollet il fait le
choix de faire ses expériences en public
et de tester il introduira notamment
l'électricité dans les salons avec son
plateau électrostatique en dehors de
l'académie des sciences il n'y a pas
qu'elle en a d'autres et de ses premiers
ouvrages de vulgarisation la science
classique correspond à la doctrine
officielle de l'église est toujours de
mise dans les universités à la sorbonne
par exemple pour l'instant les savons
qu'ils expérimentent n'ont aucun lien
officiel pour partager et se rencontrer
il passe un petit peu pour des rebelles
pourtant ces savants il cherche
intéressés par leurs travaux les
aristocrates qui sont à l'époque les
seuls qui sache à peu près lire et
écrire un conte soient d'accord ne parle
pas de culture pour tous et ça marche
c'est aristo agissent peu à peu comme
des mécènes et la science va devenir à
la mode au siècle des lumières si à 50
ans t'as pas tout cabinet de curiosités
et ton club scientifique
t'as raté ta vie déjà au 18e les
sciences sont majoritairement
représentés par des hommes une femme va
s'imposer dans ce cercle de
scientifiques
c'est emilie du châtelet qui proposera
la première traduction en français de
l'oeuvre de newton principal qui
deviendra une sorte de bible dans
l'histoire des sciences modernes ici la
vulgarisation c'est la traduction fidèle
des propos newton on veut que cette
théorie soit connue en france notamment
celles sur les couleurs les fluides les
marais et les lois de la gravitation
universelle et me du châtelet et choisi
le français plutôt que le latin pour
traduire ses théories pourquoi parce
qu'à cette époque le latin ne permet
plus de traduire de nouvelles idées
plutôt que d'inventer de nouvelles
locutions latines
on préfère enrichir la langue française
et c'est son mec voltaire qui prend en
charge le côté promotionnel en donnant
conférence en conférence pour expliquer
tout cela un public mondain on va pas
s'étendre ici sur ce personnage son
oeuvre littéraire et politique
on va plutôt s'attacher ça loin une
publication celle des lettres
philosophiques est une tentative de
vulgarisation du système politique de la
grande-bretagne
l'échec fuite total voltaïque voudrait
que la france prennent modèle sur
l'angleterre au niveau du système
politique et en voulant inoculé une
petite dose de bris
isme il sous-entend qu'une constitution
et il a semblé sont souhaitables
deux choses dont la france absolutiste
n'est pas pourvu le roi louis 15 il
refuse qu'on remette en cause ses
méthodes de gouvernement
du coup il émet une lettre de cachet
contre voltaire une lettre de cachet ça
veut dire que le roi pour diverses
raisons peut décider d'arrêter des
opposants et ce sera le cas pour volta
ses écrits licencieux et parenthèses
cette possibilité de pouvoir arrêter de
manière arbitraire et l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles la révolution a été
faite fin de la parenthèse dans cet
épisode j'ai voulu vous présentez des
personnalités plus ou moins connus et
qui ont choisi de consacrer du temps à
expliquer leur découverte derrière des
intentions diverses les choix des
savants pour parler au plus grand nombre
ont toujours été la simplification de la
langue
l'amusement l'illustration et
l'expérimentation ces techniques elles
ont toujours cours à notre époque on
peut être un grand scientifique et ne
pas réussir à se faire comprendre par
tous au final s'agit pas de savoir qui
est légitime pour faire de la
vulgarisation
tout le monde est légitime pour
expliquer un fait qu'il maîtrise la
véritable question de vulgarisation est
plutôt comment de quelle manière fautive
vulgariser et en particulier notre
époque
peut-il rester sur son piédestal
scientifique et maintenir un langage c
est précis et rigoureux mais
inaccessible pour beaucoup
moi je connais un bon petit l inverse
rendre le propos bébêtes avec des
questions cons pour reprendre le titre
évocateur d'une chaîne est insinué que
les capacités intellectuelles de
l'auditeur se situe à ce niveau parce
que t'es con complètement con faut-il
tout misé sur la fin plus tôt que le
contenu faut-il s'interdire toute
ouverture qui ne fait pas consensus
et j'insiste sur le terme consensus pas
dire que les hypothèses sont fausses
enfin prenons des exemples peut être
plus précis faut-il vulgariser tel un
henri guillemin en revendiquant
clairement sa pensée politique s'exposer
de la sorte et orienter ses explications
en ce sens au détriment parfois de la
véracité des faits ou bien en version
stéphane bern tout sourire réduisant les
périodes de bouleversement
révolutionnaire ou simple anecdote d
habitude si julie qui des membres de la
cour royale
à ce propos je conseille vivement la
chaîne dystonie et sa playlist veni vidi
sensi qui a consacré deux épisodes l'un
à henri guillemin qui était un historien
très productif durant les années 60 70
à la télévision et un autre épisode
consacré à stéphane bern
il n'y a certainement pas une seule
bonne façon de vulgariser et dans toutes
celles que je viens de vous citer il ya
un tri à faire il a une critique de
bonne part à élaborer même si je vous
donne les moyens de me critiquer ou
pouvait aller cliquer sur les sources de
l'épisode est vérifié je me fous pas de
vous l'auditeur il a un rôle fondamental
dans la qualité des vidéos de
vulgarisation et je parlerai en
particulier le cas de youtube vous avez
nous avons tous la possibilité
d'interagir via cette plateforme
vous avez à disposition un espace
destiné aux commentaires usant de
manière constructive bien sûr mais posez
vos questions et je pense que c'est dans
ce sens qu'il faut aller la diffusion du
savoir c'est toujours fait et se fait
encore de façon verticale l'information
venant des hautes sphères de la société
le gouvernement au temps des rois mais
c'est aussi vrai pour les médias
aujourd'hui comme la télé par exemple de
nos jours grâce à la vulgarisation sur
internet on peut envisager une diffusion
horizontal et non plus vertical un
savoir qu'ils restent accessibles
facilement pour ceux qui le souhaitent
mais surtout qui naît d'une interaction
et d'un partage l'émission late space
alliance de darty va elodie et est en ce
sens une belle initiative
les épisodes se construisait à partir
des commentaires laissés par les abonnés
le partage des expériences sur internet
est ce que ce serait pas alors de
nouvelles l'empirisme procédant par
raccourci avec une dose de pensée
magique parfois de mélange des
influences ce qui fait qu'il ya du bon
comme du moins bon mais il ya quand même
du bon cet épisode est terminé merci à
tous de l'avoir regardé j'espère qu'il
vous a plu en tous les cas n'hésitez pas
à le partager et vous abonner à la
chaîne
vous trouverez dans la barre d'infos les
sources de l'épisode bien évidemment et
des liens vers les chaînes que j'ai
cités notamment is tony pour la playlist
veni vidi sensi à la prochaine salut